[Music]
more taco war Cody
[Music]
the Waimakariri district council has
recently reached the lease agreement
with land information New Zealand for
much of the regeneration near ELN this
is great news for our community because
we can get under way with priority
regeneration projects while we wait for
the full land investment to occur after
hearing back from the local community
Council has approved option two which
will see Cass Street closed at the
entrance to the sports and recreation
reserve and jolly Street reinstated the
rebuild of Courtney Drive has been
delayed by the discovery of asbestos
then the land underneath the existing
Road specialists have been appointed to
deal with the situation and construction
the new road will start in January work
has also begun in the cowboy food forest
fruit trees from red zone properties
have been relocated and a public
planting day recently took place we'll
have a lot more on this in our next
update
[Music]
many of the facilities proposed for the
regeneration areas are going to be great
for local youth and today we're gonna
find it how they've been involved in the
process so far and what they're excited
about i'm stands for cash-poor youth
division we are all from different
schools and we help choirboy be middle
values we are excited for the
regeneration for crackling I remember a
lot of people even though we sort of
already had by bishops a little people
put a lot of takeaways down most kids
just hang around at the library they
stay so it'll be better to actually have
somewhere where we could go maybe around
there there could be some features like
bleachers sorry if we have like a
half-court game and our parents want to
come along and they can sit on the
bleachers and watch us instead of having
to use all our petrol and like parents
stuff to take us into town and they
could for once come out to us and class
we can go pack urine throw the trees
it'd be good to have a few more than
I think I'll be good that we need some
more stuff to do with shopping and other
things besides new spaces to shop an Inc
was a popular request amongst our youth
a year ago
Holly Potomac presented ideas from tour
here we school to the Hearing Panel of
what they wanted in the recovery plan I
talked about things that I'd like to see
an area likes of retail businesses more
sports fields recreation center like
inside outside the whole food first
thing happening over here is great
because it makes me think about my
family's history of not just having to
go to new world to get food that you can
come here and I can do something during
the week in like support this whole
thing going on and help out just for the
community to come back and yeah just
something to do we also talked to the
Waimakariri Youth Council on progress at
the September meeting and they were
really keen to be involved
[Music]
a next update will be all about the
cowboy food for us this is a really
popular community live project and a lot
of work has already been done and with
the routing options confirmed we look at
the updated layer for the sport and
recreation reserved
for more information about the
regeneration visit any council service
center or Waimakariri dot govt t dot n
ZD ford slash regeneration
[Music]